think about how paired like scared some
of these these adults have been and how
how much they've been torturing their
families pushing other kids yeah like
that that's probably that is
traumatizing maya was so happy to take
the mask off dude mine's a little
anti-massacre dude she was excited she
was at school like i don't have to wear
my mask anymore she looked around she
was like why are these cucks still
wearing the mask
so she said to me dude
what the problem is is with the chinese
daddy let's say the chat is here no
one's going to do that
is [ __ ] huge and there's all these
[ __ ] slanted cooks i don't like
that sounds like your daughter yeah i
was like jeez i didn't know you felt so
strongly about it but all right in five
four
three two one hello everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast for those of you out there who
have not heard of the genius brain
podcast you're a [ __ ] idiot nobody
loves you when you were born you were
found in a garbage can and somebody
tried to light it on fire but it didn't
happen because you are flame [ __ ]
didn't
anyways that works though it worked now
i'm cancelled amazing it's okay that
wraps up this season at the genius brave
podcast
patrick.t
dot riley legal name mm-hmm
full last name and then we have nick
the
ear bang a solid member of the jk news
crew now solid that get me out of there
bro oh man dude oh man dude get me out
of i heard it smells like a jar of
pickles and jacob you know
as soon as we're done filming for the
week i'm like don't talk to me for a
whole two weeks that's why i tell you
all the guys
don't reach out to me don't talk to me
because as soon as you do jk news for
that long you don't want to talk to
[ __ ] anybody it's tiring man it's a
hard job i sit and and it's like you
know we're [ __ ] around [ __ ] and like
shooting the [ __ ]
but man your brain i i don't think my
brain can handle the nonsense that goes
in that [ __ ] room eight hours of
nonsense is a lot we're just that's kind
of our [ __ ] bro dude we used to we
used to shoot like 10 11 hours dude damn
i don't know how you guys missed
nonsense 40 articles in a day and even
like listening and like actively
listening to somebody for that long too
much
is really hard
oh for sure like in a row the way that
like the the show is scheduled
it's just like man when we were doing jk
news back in the day i remember like
certain people who are avid avid
listeners and watchers of that show they
would know when which episodes that we
shot late at night because we were just
crazy we were just like [ __ ] insane
yeah nothing ever made sense in any of
those episodes and it was always the
funniest ones it's a real bathroom dude
it's a real meth room yeah it just gets
like the first one you're very concise
with your words and your thoughts and
then after a while it's just pure
nonsense because you don't know what the
[ __ ] going on damn bro could you
imagine 40 in a day oh my gosh [ __ ]
40 dude we would do 20 and then 20. too
much content yeah i i literally lost my
mind and it was fun though i'll tell you
that yeah yeah but now you guys got
alcohol there so it gets a little crazy
when are you gonna come back are you
gonna come back
probably not like i had a lot of things
to do
come on man please no please please
gracious with your presence come on
please no no no i'll stop it for maybe a
couple episodes show my penis walk on
the [ __ ] out nice that sounds like a
good deal i think we need that jump i
think we need that boost in the views i
think if you're listening right now if
you hear a leaf blower why the [ __ ]
would you guys clean my yard right now
this is to you yeah [ __ ] you
usually come later what the [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] my whole thing up so funniest
thing that happened ever once again this
world that we live in [ __ ] crazy the
life of a movie bro ryan coogler if you
don't know who ryan coogler is let me
give you some background information
don't know who he is right ryan coogler
cool very name very famous director out
of oakland oakland california
black panther just to give you guys a
quick [ __ ] refresher coogler
fruitvale too right did you do this
station truvail station with uh what's
michael jordan michael b jordan he also
did the creed series hold on a second
hold on leaf blower
what's up homie not a coogler's fan he's
like i know you guys are filming right
now so i'm gonna put the leaf blower
right by the door
we'll just wait like three minutes
oh wow
this is cool though
ryan coogler is the [ __ ] super [ __ ]
good so the funniest thing that happened
which by the way
does not seem real ryan coogler needed
to take out twelve thousand dollars from
uh bank of america okay right but i
think he was like in kind of like a cd
neighborhood and twelve thousand dollars
is a lot of [ __ ] cash so in order for
people not to know how much money he's
taking out
he decides to write on a piece of paper
okay and mind you he has a mask on why
kovid okay and he writes like could you
discreetly
um i need twelve thousand dollars and i
could you please do it discreetly
because he doesn't wanna you know cause
a commotion or whatever [ __ ] yeah
and it says withdraw it doesn't say put
twelve thousand money twelve thousand
dollars in the bag you stupid ugly
crusty [ __ ]
it was that's a threat he goes he goes
could you do it in the back and please
do it discreetly
and he writes it on a piece of paper
never seen a bank robber do this in my
life and she goes and talks to the
manager and then they [ __ ] arrest him
for trying to rob the bank wow
how weird is this [ __ ] dude she must be
tripping that's his next movie though
right there she went to her manager too
and the manager didn't even check
so she was she went to the back she
talked to the manager the manager was
like ah okay yeah clearly he's a black
male he's robbing us first of all black
people don't rob banks that's a white
person thing yeah okay phone with dick
and jane you're getting that movie get
your [ __ ] grace is right yeah oh wait
how could you you keep 11. you can't
even you can't even rob a bank anymore
honestly
now you can't it's not like the good old
days man how you're going to get caught
100. they have yeah how do you get away
with them a thousand different security
alarms that no one knows they have
snipers on buildings like you're not
you're [ __ ] don't they have the blue
ink when you open up the door yeah that
happens it just shoots in your face they
have tracers too how do you stop that
how do you stop painting how do you you
got to wash the money don't you
you got to wash it let's start oh no it
was more racist
after after an investigation the police
say this was just all a huge mistake and
the fault lies with the uh bank of
america employee who described in the
report
ryan coogler as a pregnant black woman
a pregnant black woman that's what she
should you know what she's trying to say
she's trying to say the the masks the
mask like she can't wait to identify
that's a good cop-out that's a good
defense i'm not buying it though but
what is this bank so she she
first of all ryan coogler she's reaching
and she's like this is a pregnant black
woman that's what she thinks right and
she's like this pregnant black woman is
trying to rob us
even though they gave the male the
account has a guy's name it says ryan
coogler but she's like nah this is still
a pregnant black woman ryan ryan could
be a female name as well yeah i think he
has a beard too doesn't he yes facial
hair he looks like a guy yeah what's up
with this bank who's the bank yeah yeah
did they check the blood of the [ __ ]
bank teller there's clearly this good
she's high
well did you arrest the dragon
did you hear the dragon that was flying
around
yeah you didn't see the dragon guys
there's a cyclops is there information
on what race she is
i i'm pretty sure she's not black
but i want to assume she's out of her
[ __ ] mind whatever race she is
how the [ __ ] did you think that that
dude was a pregnant black woman
wait i want to see who's the bank of the
can we do this
identify her who is the bank they didn't
have they will never identify her they
can't bro he's wearing a [ __ ]
like a beanie like a snug beanie and a
hoodie how the [ __ ] does he look
anything like a pregnant pregnant woman
at all that doesn't look like a problem
how does he walk though huh how does he
how do you walk through the door
sometimes some dudes will be walking
with their hips switching a little
breaking a little pregnancy you have
like a little auntie walking yeah a
pregnant walk
what if he was like a little bloated and
he was walking off funny and he was like
holding the stomach we don't know yeah
we don't know that's so [ __ ]
hilarious i i i can't believe that she
actually said to the cops i thought he
was a pregnant black woman she's lying
she and then also they talked for like
at least said hello to each other so you
hear a guy's voice she's saving face
everything she's saying is like like
backtracking excuses that makes no sense
she's making she's saying excuses when
you find out that you're racist a little
bit
that's like some nervous [ __ ] right yeah
like oh no i thought he was a pregnant
woman
this woman is high as [ __ ] for sure
there's absolutely no [ __ ] way dude
so here's the question does she keep her
job i thought it was a small chinese man
for sure she's a bank manager now that's
how b of a works but i i it's funny
because everybody on twitter is going
off right now saying that i will never
bank at bank of america i don't think
this is bank of america's fault i think
it's just these two [ __ ] dumb
individuals yeah you're gonna just take
all your money out of bank of america
because these two are idiots yeah yeah
what if that's the only bank in your in
your area what happens then
the [ __ ] are you talking about like
there's plenty of other people out there
like
what what is this pure nonsense we need
to follow this like there should be a
camera on this late i want to see like
what her daily interactions are like if
she's just calling everybody
no just how off she is all the time you
know like she's
like she thought this dude was like a
chinese dude or some [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ] is this
how do you make it in life with these
kind of perceptions you know she i i'm
pretty sure she's high she has to be on
drugs she had to be there's no [ __ ]
way she's not on drugs she had to be
high all right i think you're a
drugstore she probably took an edible
and then went to work
i bet you because i if i was on the
edible i'll be paranoid sometimes i'll
be thinking sometimes people say [ __ ] to
me and i don't even know because the
note is really clear there's nothing
vague about it when he says 12 000 out
of my account there's no way that
somebody who is sane that's a
functioning human being would look at
that and say clearly he's robbing the
bank for only twelve thousand dollars
yeah right what if she just got robbed
though what if the bank just got robbed
and it was a similar incident and we're
not twelve thousand dollars today yeah
we're not saying
ever yeah
yeah why only 12 g's i know like what
what a low what a low aim you know
people do while [ __ ] all the time though
like because i'm sure people are like
skits out of their mind you know they do
like wild [ __ ] so i'm sure there's crazy
requests he's a very famous bank robber
the low self-esteem bankrupt
i'm only worth twelve thousand dollars
he's humble bro
the tellers are like dude believe in
yourself yeah yeah he's like you gotta
ask for more you can ask for more you
guys walk through the door again try
that again
try to get with a different amount okay
give me twelve thousand dollars [ __ ] no
no change the added zero yeah yeah oh
i'm sorry that goes back 120 thousand
dollars there you got more zero you
could do it yeah 1.2 million he's like
no you gotta do it again i didn't buy it
i didn't buy it weirdest thing ever dude
well people like there was a story on uh
that we did that we talked about where
i got in the roscoe's in pasadena a guy
just went up in there with a gun and a
big
like trash bag and was like give me all
the chicken he didn't even want money he
wanted the chicken he's one of the
churches the most amazing thing i've
ever heard in my life that is like you
know you never know what these people's
stories are you never know what their
motivation for being they're like what's
the recipe
oh give me the guy
write it down
and pepper you dumb [ __ ] write it in
grams right in the ground yeah i need
the exact measurement and the waffle mix
what's the waffle mix because the
waffles are [ __ ] good there's
cinnamon in it for sure
maybe some nuts maybe there's no
cinnamon no nutmeg
you're lying i want make one in front of
me right now i love that
taste
we call that [ __ ] the banana cream
pudding [ __ ] oh that's just hella good
at roscoe's i never had that banana
crusher because i could get the the
[ __ ] nilla wafers and then banana
pudding and [ __ ] and whipped cream whoa
it's a secret menu that's a secret menu
oh no dog that's just it's on there all
the time
if you have a little white in your blood
you can't see [ __ ]
it's like yeah
it's right
it's like
right now he locks it half
[ __ ] i want that [ __ ] too you get
grilled chicken that's what you that's
[ __ ] whack dog i want to see that man
i miss when [ __ ] before kobet
roscoe's used to be opened up super late
they're not open late anymore i think
that they close like ten or nine or some
[ __ ] the one that passes it used to be
open till like [ __ ] 12 or two
so sad you know what's good too speaking
of do cindy's an eagle rock banana cream
pie
amazing
cindy's there's a diner in eagle rock
called cindy's the food there kind of
sucks the banana cream pie though is
incred if you just want banana cream pie
they make bomb ass pies fresh there
banana cream pie yo we gotta talk about
this [ __ ] so it's so [ __ ] funny this
little pat hits us up
about the south pasadena drama that's
happening oh yeah yeah
stupid let me tell you something that
was actually sent to me an article was
sent to me and who sent it to you nikki
sent it to me and i know you guys are
close to constant pie so i was like i
got to send this to you
eatery
i love this so good so much to the point
where people think i own it okay i don't
own it i just post about it you do post
about it yeah you're like a silent
partner or something it's not my
restaurant at all whatsoever i just love
the place
i [ __ ] love the people that work
there right yeah some of the sweetest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
people will tag like at davidson's
restaurant i'm like bro that's the
fattest thing you could ever tag me at
dude yeah yeah it's not even my
restaurant but low-key though if you did
have a restaurant and you were to hire
like chefs to create them it'd be that
it would be very similar i think i think
it would be on par so like they so if
you guys have ever heard of like the
next door app right hilarious app the
one of the funniest [ __ ] things ever
because it's literally twitter for old
ass people yeah they literally post
about everything and anything today i
woke up and a bird was chirping and i
loved it i'm like yeah thanks grandma
shut the [ __ ] up people are always
questioning if there's gunshots and i'm
like there's not this many gunshots i
literally saw one post it said the the
title was i saw a coyote like that's
what it said
and then you click on it and then what
he wrote was it was outside in the past
like
[ __ ] yeah dude i did my d for the day i
alerted the neighborhood
the thing for the next door app too if
you want to get to know your neighbors
yeah it's really good if you want to
hate your neighbors yeah yeah so i got
to know my neighbors through the
nextdoor app and then people welcome you
if you're like in a really tight-knit
community but the other downside of the
nextdoor app is that when people start
making a scene about nothing things just
blow up because nobody has anything
better to do so there was a guy his name
is mike
first and last name punk [ __ ]
[ __ ] by the way he took his post
down good because he was getting heat
for it he's a scumbag so this guy writes
his post on the nextdoor app about this
lovely local eatery which by the way
everybody [ __ ] loves everybody loves
it we know the owners everybody they
know them that they gave us free
baked goods this guy ate a cookie off
the [ __ ] floor like a savage and she
gave me another one
that's how good it is not on the floor
that's how stupid and disgusting he is i
just put that in just where everybody
knows no but the cookie is very good
though it was very good it almost kind
of tasted better on the floor
yeah seasoning sochi bakes everything
herself
delicious pounds of butter and
everything it's the best
butter you read on the next door at this
guy mike starts writing this skating
review of the restaurant and the shitty
thing about that is too is like number
one restaurants are [ __ ] suffering
right now because of pandemic everything
has gone up in cost and we all know this
stuff right obviously we talked about
the gas situation
this podcast is brought to you by better
help online therapy relationships take
work especially the most important one
you can have in your life your
relationship with yourself a lot of us
will drop anything to go help someone we
care about we'll go out of our way to
treat other people well but how often do
we give ourselves the same treatment my
friends treat yourself to your mental
health by getting better help i have
used better help a lot of listeners have
used better help and i've talked about
and they've been a long time sponsor
because better help works it's something
that i have in my tool bag whenever i
need mental clarity whenever i need to
talk to somebody better help is there
for me it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours you
could have phone sessions uh live video
chat sessions whatever you want if you
don't want to see anybody you can even
turn off your camera it doesn't matter
it's there for you this podcast is
sponsored by better helping genius brain
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
genius that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
genius
so he writes a scathing review saying
that
he his daughter his sweet little
daughter
decided to order a sandwich right they
were asking she was asking for a turkey
sandwich and she got the order wrong
right that the restaurant did
and um she got an uh uh their labt
instead
which is also a great sandwich and so
she said that the owner
he started yelling at the young girl
right basically just verbally abusing
her saying you know making her feel like
she's dumb for getting the wrong
sandwich and he wrote that his daughter
bawled her eyes out that she cried
so though everybody in the neighborhood
just starts ripping into the restaurant
over a [ __ ] sandwich
guess what this guy lied he also wrote
that they made him pay for both
sandwiches he [ __ ] lied so this d-bag
by the way guess how old the daughter is
it's like 21. yeah she should have cried
she's an adult so he wrote the post as
if it was like a six-year-old girl yeah
to make them look like they're terrible
people yeah and so she wasn't even aware
of this until they found out that their
neighbors were telling them what's going
on with your restaurant like people in
the neighborhood are upset she goes over
what so it turns out that this girl
is not even a child she's a full-grown
[ __ ] adult but he lied about that he
made it seem like he was a little child
one of the most manipulative that's
annoying dude pieces of [ __ ] ever and
then he also wrote that he had to pay
for both sandwiches she posted the
receipt saying no you got your full
refund back you know what he writes back
he goes well it didn't hit my bank
account yet oh
i want to punch this guy in the face you
believe this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and so he has nothing to say and then
the people in the comments are hilarious
and this is what i love about the
nextdoor app somebody wrote like
somebody wrote at the bottom of the
comment that maybe die laughing ahead
like 100 likes
it's a [ __ ] sandwich
yeah it's real [ __ ] sandwich it's a
sandwich [ __ ] so what really happened
was this shut up is that this girl yeah
you shut up you're ugly
so this girl comes in she
tries to order the sandwich right and
this is what i asked them she goes
number one i should if you've ever met
sochi she doesn't yell she's the
sweetest
she's so soft smoking
super sausage this woman bakes cookies
for a living dude yeah and so it's an
adorable she says no that's not what
happened this is what happened
she ordered she wanted to know what
certain stamp and she was unsure and
when she ordered the labt i made sure i
was like this doesn't have turkey this
is a basically an uh
a blt yeah but it has avocados this is
what you want and she goes yeah that's
what i want he goes okay cool she orders
it she picks up her sandwich she goes
the sandwich doesn't have turkey in it
oh she goes i know i clarify with you if
you wanted the labt which is a blt
sandwich you get the turkey sandwich or
you wanted the turkey club sandwich or
whatever she's delicious also oh okay
and then you know she starts like
freaking out a little bit and then
there's nothing wrong with it
so apparently she goes back tells her
parents what happens which by the way
you're a [ __ ] grown ass adult yeah
you see her her mom comes in and starts
[ __ ] yelling at them over the phone
oh screams like you say you you're
belittling your customers making them
feel like they're [ __ ] stupid wow off
on them yeah and so but this guy this
daughter doesn't know how to read a
[ __ ] menu bro this is what i truly
believe though
i i don't i don't know this guy mike but
i i do truly i really do think that the
the girl probably has like some kind of
like social issues and he was just
defending his daughter but he did he
went a little too far so he took things
a lot more personally and she's probably
been bullied before this stuff before
yeah so they're just so used to
defending their kid that is now an adult
they just kind of went to ham on it no
that's too understanding [ __ ] this full
he's evil dog yeah yeah yeah no no but
that makes a lot of sense i'm trying to
be yeah because it makes sense that's
what it seems like at this point but the
problem with him is the lying part
and also too why are you going out if
you would destroy a small bit because it
ruins your point it ruins everything
that you have to say now you're a liar
now we can't trust your word for this
whole story this whole narrative you
placed
that you put on the internet for other
people to read that are like they're
just scrolling through you know so
you're a [ __ ] loser dude exactly
don't you have [ __ ] to do dog did he
have a bunch of other uh posts too he
had a bunch so a majority of his post is
him complaining about some [ __ ] so
he's the problem do you have it like
don't you have a job yeah relax
how do you have the time i don't [ __ ]
know here's this here's how i knew he
was a liar
because when they wrote back oh the
other thing that they lied about too
they said that a man was yelling at him
the main chef which is her husband
doesn't answer the phones okay it was
her she picked up the phone he also said
it was a guy that was yelling at a girl
to make it look like a male was yelling
at a little child like that's a juicy
smoothie too
he also said that a large black man came
in and started beating him up and he was
trying to face
supremacist african-american beat me up
is what he said
this guy just kept lying constantly
throughout this whole post there were so
many things that were wrong with it and
he was trying to destr like it's not
even the fact that i know these people i
just hate it when people do that
i hate what it is is because restaurants
it's all customer service
and everyone uh kind of we all know that
they're there to help you out right like
that's like the whole that's everybody
every restaurant so you get these
[ __ ] [ __ ] that like are like you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna take
advantage of that and i'm gonna treat
these people like [ __ ] because i just
wanna treat someone like [ __ ] that's why
those people need to get their [ __ ]
ass as well yeah there's one of those
situations where like that guy like that
lady yelling on the phone like if if the
other person on like the business owner
was so inclined to they should be
allowed to hang that phone up and then
find go to that person's house and just
start [ __ ] them up and i think that
that would be legally okay i actually
know where the school lives oh you do
yeah i know exactly where he lives i
know he lives yeah my way is god damn
dude
no i didn't do that that's kind of rude
but honestly we i think that's right
that you're understanding because like
this guy could just be you know having a
bad day his [ __ ] daughter could be
shitty but yeah it was definitely a
piece of [ __ ] move he for sure was lying
and the reason why i knew he was lying
because after they wrote that hey your
wife actually came and just you know
berated us on the phone he goes that's
impossible my wife is the sweetest
person ever lies
no husband ever says that about their
[ __ ] wife yeah you're [ __ ] lying
yeah exactly what sucks my wife has
never done an evil thing in her life
please bro he knows he's lying on the
[ __ ] he's the same husband ever says
that about their wife if he was like
dude you know what she's kind of a [ __ ]
bag but she would never do that i would
believe him yeah right exactly yeah
that's way more believable you're a
[ __ ] liar your wife's a saint please
stop my nutsack dude yeah
mike actually found his facebook and i
just kind of went through it what kind
of poster
you have
you're really interested he's constantly
ranting into his facebook all the time
see
you can't trust these guys you can't
trust the ranters because they always
have a [ __ ] angle
like all the people that
that post reviews all the time and you
look at their stuff i bet he if i bet if
he has a yelp account he's over here
well he claims that he doesn't have a
yelp and he never
expected next door exactly
but sean you're an active you can't be
active on multiple social media
platforms like this right active duty
complaining oh that's all that's your
content you just complain i don't
understand though it's like why do you
go out of your way to destroy somebody's
business over a turkey sandwich
a [ __ ] sandwich you dweeb and if
there were some people below in the
comments that were like you know what
i've never been there but now i will
never go there and i'm going to do a
petition you're a [ __ ] dude you know
what even happens
i don't know they got a call from
somebody else
the restaurant threatening the
restaurant saying like we have a group
of people that are coming over right now
to boycott your restaurant and i'm like
okay and this person was going off on
them and then they explained to him what
happened they go did you know that the
person because i can't believe that you
would harass a little child and then she
goes the woman it's a grown woman
and after she told that she goes i am so
sorry
i had no idea we had no idea we thought
this was a little girl yeah over his
post yeah that's crazy and they
apologized dude next door this guy's a
great right nice door's kind of causing
some [ __ ] there's about to be [ __ ]
frankenstein riots outside of the place
gaston over here dude but that but
that's a certain neighborhood though
that neighborhood they kind of need the
action they need need they need the
drama the other one i sent you was
hilarious too about that guy yeah so the
the the post is you saw it too right
that they couldn't i couldn't read it so
okay i'll have the app there's a picture
the picture is this white dude and he's
like it's a picture of him with his
phone he's about to take a picture of
the person he's arguing with the van
right and then the post is like watch
out for this [ __ ] or whatever
something like that and it's like this
guy uh apparently she had a biden harris
uh bumper sticker and he like chased her
he like pulled over and was like you're
a communist piece of [ __ ]
he's just a temporariest woman i started
yelling at her and all these comments
like other people started commenting
like oh yeah this guy's yelled at me
like this guy's a menace like he just
goes around and just starts yelling
mother [ __ ] up at people whatever
and then what was great is that i've
actually served him where i work i've
served him and he did tell me not to get
vaccinated but he tipped me really well
so i was
i like back i was like i don't know for
a hundred percent if i if this is true
but i have a pretty good feeling that
this dude has a fat dick that's what i
wrote
and where there's you know what the [ __ ]
i wish i noticed this because next door
apps like you're just saying has some of
the most ridiculous commentary this
person who wrote that they were harassed
by this guy where he was saying like
salacious [ __ ] she also writes i
reported him to the mailman oh yeah yeah
like what the [ __ ] is the fail man
citizen's arrest
she goes i went to the post offices and
i reported them to the post office i'm
pretty sure who was whoever was working
there was like
get the [ __ ] out of here you're like
what am i supposed to do dude i bet what
if the mailman did like just do a barrel
roll and just [ __ ] pulls a revolver
around
bro the post office is so weird
especially that one i've had
interactions too where i went to go drop
off mail and i remember this one time
this late this older lady came up to and
she was like drop this off for me like i
don't know like i'm walking into the
building like you work there she came up
to me she's like dropped this off for me
and i was like i just kind of was like i
didn't grab her envelope yeah and then
she was like take she's like ah [ __ ]
i'll just do it myself like no one wants
to do anything about and i was like
what the [ __ ] i was like that's weird as
[ __ ] i'm not gonna get your mail and
drop it off for you i was like why would
i do that she's like i have a bad back
that's what she said to me and i was
like okay [ __ ] like yo these people are
crazy like this [ __ ] male 1 touching
your weird what you got drugs what is
this cocaine in there my fingerprints
now i go to jail for your stupid [ __ ]
oh that's right you know i get paranoid
with her no she was just like i just
started laughing what happened after you
guys hooked up dude
we worked it out we worked it out yeah
that's how it work man
but yeah there's weirdos around that
post office you hang around there you're
gonna see some [ __ ] crack off i don't
know what it is about that i understand
now why [ __ ] post office people just
sometimes don't have the best attitude
they got to deal with a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the crazy people and they
get the worst questions too like if you
wait in line and you're trying to like
ship something out the pers like the
three people before you always ask the
worst questions you're stupid questions
that it's like you guys if you guys just
did a little research
holographic go for nowadays
do you guys still use the same type of
glue on your envelopes 30 years ago
excuse me idiot move yeah right who the
[ __ ] cares by the way i'm actually
quoting what somebody asked no at the
post office no way and you could tell
like this worker was just like the [ __ ]
it's the busiest time of day i don't
know what glue these envelopes use what
are you talking about elmer's glue [ __ ]
the white one with the cow on it use
this glue and [ __ ] it right between your
thin little lips shut your [ __ ] mouth
and keep moving yeah yeah yeah god bless
you god loves you
keep it moving
god damn it dude
the dmv same [ __ ] oh no dude i went
there recently terrible it's pretty nice
they got the systems figured out oh kind
of what are you talking about they're
starting to get it a little tighter yeah
they're nice but but you see how some of
these dmv people they're they are snappy
and i think it's from past trauma from
all the people it's just too much [ __ ]
they gotta deal they gotta deal with the
forms the [ __ ]
like places giving people instructions
like that is i'm sure a nightmare nobody
goes to the dmv with all the things they
need everybody has something i bring
every form of identification i have
possible yeah just in case because i do
not want to wait in line again and go
back i'm going to get there and i'm
going to get my [ __ ] done people in
general when you go to the stores or
anything they're just meaner to you just
in general what stores just any stores
except for retail and pie dudes people
i've
the places that always had good service
maintain that but i think everyone is
just so sick of all these weird requests
and like
like i was talking to someone who was a
gym owner
and they were talking about how people
will email them
and say like so what's your mass policy
and it's like a jiu jitsu gym
and it's like
they're saying look we're not wearing
masks because
we're doing jiu jitsu so the math stuff
like you're gonna get covet if you're
gonna if you have it if somebody we're
just risking it at this point we don't
give a [ __ ] you know and then and then
you get the other like fringe of people
that are like hey like are you guys
checking for vaccine cards and then some
places are like no and they go thank god
like let me tell you about all these
other places i've been to that's the
most annoying thing it's like i don't
care to have a vaccine conversation with
you yeah shut the [ __ ] up people are so
ready to talk about all this yeah
they're like dudes these people out here
who believe in the vaccines they're
[ __ ] just commune i don't
care yeah what do you want to drink
be quiet and then when they have the
conversation with you and then you give
them just a little pushback to whatever
they're saying
then they go oh they started judging
like oh i didn't know you were there i'm
just an [ __ ] i didn't know you were
this they go are you vaccinated i'm like
oh i have no vaccines at all
a political conversation now i'm like
just give me my sandwich yeah i don't
care there was a waiter too that was
they wanted to talk about um
the whole vaccine thing like oh god you
know people in l.a they're just so
serious about it get me my water i don't
care yeah like you're on the clock in my
water so i can give you a tip if you
keep talking about this [ __ ] you'll get
no tip because i'm thirsty yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
butcher box listen if you have been
following me especially on my instagram
you have been seeing me cook over
hot hot hardwood flames well guess what
the meat that i'm cooking on over these
hot hot hardwood flames is the meat that
i'm getting from butcher
box bircher box is a subscription
service that takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality meat butcher box
sources their meat from partners with
the highest standards of quality no more
searching the grocery store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild caught seafood and more
their sourcing decisions are made
holistically keeping the farmer the
planet and animal and your family in
mind once again you guys know follow me
on my instagram you'll see me cook up a
lot of stuff over hot hot wooden flames
and i'm always cooking up a variety of
meats whether it's chicken beef or
whatever it all comes from butcher box
and it's so
[ __ ]
good high quality meat i don't have to
think about it it's honestly the best
and every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality right
to your home free shipping for the
continental u.s no antibiotics or added
hormones pack fresh is shipped frozen
for convenience for you this is your
chance to never have to shop for ground
beef again that's right butcher box is
giving new members free ground beef for
life plus get a 10 off coupon sign up at
butcherbox.com brain and get two pounds
of ground beef for free in every order
for the life of your membership plus a
10 off coupon log on to butcherbox.com
brain to claim this deal stop talking to
me
and why are you bringing this up right
now you don't see i'm sitting here with
two other people you [ __ ] yeah i'm
trying to have a good time what do you
want me to sing with you like [ __ ] man
everybody's so socially awkward now
what's going on with people yeah dude
that's a whole nother thing too i bet
like um the same buddy same person i was
talking to
they they like deal with kids and they
coach kids and they're saying like
dude these kids are a little like uh
they're not really used to conversating
with like adults and now some there's
like a subset of kids that like won't
even dare put their mask on or anything
at all i mean uh take it off like wow
that they're trying to talk to you in
the eyes like they feel like oh i need
to put hand sanitizer all the time you
know because
you think about it like oh [ __ ] like in
the next couple years we're gonna see
the effects of like lockdowns and think
about how paired like scared some of
these these adults have been yeah how
how much they've been torturing their
[ __ ] kids
yeah like that that's probably that is
traumatizing maya was so happy to take
the mask off dude mine's a little
anti-massacre dude yeah she was excited
she was at school like i don't have to
wear my mask anymore she looked around
she was like why are these cucks still
wearing the mask
so she said to me dude
what the problem is is with the chinese
daddy let's just say the chatty's here
no one's going to do that
it's [ __ ] huge and there's all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] slanted cooks i don't like
them i was like wow that sounds like
your daughter yeah i was like jeez i
didn't know you felt so strongly about
it but all right
and it's good that you support her she's
like but anyways this is what i finger
painted today
she watched it yeah
the room and i was like wow there's a
lot of masks
are you talking like that
she's calling people cucks left and
right at preschool i was like wow
okay some of those kids are cucks though
right
we were talking about earlier
uh before the podcast that uh one of my
favorite [ __ ] uh from the south
rappers is doing stand-up ti baby
and i showed them a clip or they had to
look it up themselves and i'm curious to
know what you all think about ti stand
up
i think what everyone else thinks he's
not ready yet it's okay
it's just weird to see
because obviously his fame everyone
wants to see it but
um i i heard somebody say i forgot who
it was it was a comedian he was like
dude everyone disrespects stand-up
comedy so hard because it's like the one
thing that like everyone's just like ah
like [ __ ] it i'll just try stand-up
comedy but it's actually it's such a
hard [ __ ] thing to do really well um
and it takes so long to get really good
at it that it is kind of funny i mean i
personally i'm not i'm not mad at it i'm
not like look anyone can do whatever the
[ __ ] they want to do you know um but it
is funny to see like what was it like
you have to go through years of [ __ ]
bombing and [ __ ] and it's it takes a
certain kind of person that will endure
that to get to the other side i just
also think too for somebody like t.i
right he's he already has such a big
name to himself no matter what he's
going to go up and he's going to draw a
crowd sure so it gives him false
confidence in his jokes yeah and the the
reality of the situation is if you've
ever seen his stand-up online you could
watch clips of it 20 minutes of him just
saying absolutely nothing and the reason
why is because he's not getting booed
he's not getting real feedback and you
don't you never learn from that type of
stuff everyone's just watching they're
just watching they're just watching the
spectacle of this guy just talking like
a southern baptist pastor just
saying nothing
you know but eventually people are going
to get tired of it oh it's already
happening now yeah people start just
feeling like nah like
i'm not gonna come watch that [ __ ] you
know these [ __ ] [ __ ] out here
they just you know expeditiously
expeditiously
that's a good word
this is that's his [ __ ] he's just
rambling
yeah
he's gonna have a compliment i think
he's gonna have a kramer moment he might
have a kramer moment
what oh what racial group does he attack
his cramer definitely middle eastern
people i was thinking the same thing
actually you think so i was thinking the
same i don't know why i was feeling it
but my heart said middle eastern
i don't know do you know about the
specific drama between him and godfrey
where i got mad he got bumped right no i
heard that godfrey was headlining and
then t.i went on afterwards or something
and then but i didn't listen to the
whole thing but there was like beef
uh
because
you know the headliner's supposed to be
the last one or whatever and i don't
know if he took that disrespectfully
some that's all i heard i think there's
more to the story but that's something
that i heard i heard i think t.i went on
godfrey's podcast after and they they
talked about it oh really yeah i didn't
get to see it but i think that's the
general gist of it that he did like a
15-minute set after godfrey's which i
think godfrey
i think he allowed it but he didn't care
to see it you know or watch it sure and
t.i might have felt i mean everybody can
fact check this i'm this is very loose
information but
i think there was just like a little bit
of an issue with that because godfrey
openly said on his podcast he goes
you're not a stand-up comic i don't i
don't care to watch your set you know
there's so much ego and comedy bro it's
just like everyone shut the [ __ ] up like
this let's just have it like go up there
be funny and let's just have a good time
yeah you know yeah like i've met a lot
of dudes where like there's just an
insane amount of ego and it's just like
dude like stop taking yourself so
seriously like it doesn't [ __ ] matter
like also when you suck don't talk like
just be quiet if you're not good you're
a good rule in life you're not good but
like i said there's also some of these
other like like stand-up comics too they
like to push garbage all the time just
because then he goes like oh you can do
it you should do it man your set's great
don't give false hope to these people
yeah right tell them they're trash so
they can get better yeah yeah it's like
be honest that set wasn't [ __ ] good
you're doing old jokes that everybody
heard think of some new [ __ ] but they
never do that you know what's weird too
sometimes i've seen comics go up there
and have really bad sets and then come
off stage and think that they did good
yes where it's like where i've been like
damn like that was like i'd be i would
be really sad right like even if i was
like they might have got like a couple
chuckles here and there but like not
nowhere like it was an like if i had to
rate this it was an f like you failed
the performance and they're like yeah
man i got a good time and i was like
you're never gonna get better dude
that's so weird i [ __ ] didn't because
you you're terrible and i've i've seen
dudes do it for like a long time where
i've been like wow like you really need
to how are you not like how do you not
feel that that's what i love about bill
burr because i forgot who told me this
story but bill bird i guess
brendan shaw went on stage and you know
he's new at this point but he didn't do
very well sure and people were kind of
like giggling and laughing and then bill
bird goes up on stage he goes hey if
he's not [ __ ] funny don't laugh yeah
like don't do that [ __ ] yeah but that's
bill burr though yeah you know i think
he's genuinely trying to help him out he
goes you don't have to [ __ ] laugh at
his jokes if he's not [ __ ] funny
don't laugh you're not helping him you
know
what i don't get is because bombing
hurts so much like bomb like a [ __ ]
serious bomb i refuse to go through that
it doesn't feel good at all like i
remember like i've bombed and i've been
like i stayed to the end of the show
because it's like the respectful thing
to do and stuff but i was like i want to
run away right now like i just want to
dip like just get off the stage and just
run and then you try watch people
actually do a good job yeah yeah exactly
it's like bring the crowd back just get
in my car and just drive off a pier into
the ocean like this
should just drown like just not even
move like
but
i i like i said i don't know how certain
people i i like i said their ego plays
into it and you're dealing with crazy
[ __ ] and comedians anyway so
yeah but it's true stand-up comedy is
definitely disrespected a lot it is it's
like the one thing in entertainment
everybody goes i can do that too so yeah
yeah it's very disrespectful i mean yeah
you see like actors jump into it or
rappers sing like what the [ __ ] it's
pretty odd that t.i
decided to like his next venture was
like i'mma do stan especially because
he's just not funny he's not a very
serious guy i'm not i mean he's very
serious i'm not against people like
because i like stevo when he started
doing stand-up a lot of people hated on
him for it and look i'm hopi if anyone
cuz look there's a chance like maybe you
are good at stand up you know like try
it see if it is for you but the thing is
is like the the act of people jumping in
and being like oh yeah like i'll just
pick this [ __ ] up and i got this like
that's where it's like no they're just
talking on stage come on yeah like it's
like telling jokes i'm funny i could
tell some jokes i think for me it's not
even that it says if t.i
if i saw t i do stand up i'm not
thinking he's bad immediately i'm like
oh [ __ ] let's see what he has and yeah
he's terrible yeah that's what's
annoying to me it's like how did you how
do you get to be 15 minutes after a
headliner somebody who has put the blood
sweat and tears in and is actually
really one of the funnier comics out
there yeah and then you get to headline
his headline show just because you're ti
yeah yeah yeah sure that's like you know
t.i doing his concert right and then
godfrey goes look i've been working on
my rap after you're done with your con
i'm gonna finish it off yeah
and i'm gonna do my song yeah it's like
ti probably be like nah that's not gonna
happen yeah yeah that makes sense he
feels like he could command the state
and once again there's probably a whole
backstory that i don't know about maybe
the club was okay with it there's
there's other stuff that we don't really
know yeah but it's just very odd like i
just don't like that he's just
dropping the line basically yeah how
come people just can't work on their
[ __ ] in silence and then come out when
they're better i guess it would just be
hard if you're like that kind of big of
a dude but you're right maybe like even
going hey can i get five minutes like a
guest spot up front cold open or just go
to open mics even though people would
for sure like if ti is that [ __ ] an
open mic everyone's gonna show up
anyways but yeah i mean you're right
it's like maybe you should just go
through the same process like his sets
too like nobody has ever told him as
he's doing like multiple sets a night
hey get to your [ __ ] joke
yeah get to your joke
he just ran and he talks so slow super
slow he's commanding the stage as he as
if he has like dave chappelle clout in
comedy yeah but he doesn't talk about
anything he's just sitting there just
saying the most basic jokes like hey you
know [ __ ] you know what you know man
people crazy yeah people be crazy out
here they come back expeditiously coming
down
i mean he should honestly do a whole set
about how he [ __ ] um checks his
daughter to see if she still has her
hymen oh that's weird yup he doesn't
remember that yep that's the thing that
was a huge controversy on the show he i
think he was exaggerating oh was he i
think he was for real i don't think he
actually goes how do you you got to put
your fingers in your dog you would tell
the doctor
oh really he would tell the gynecologist
to make sure so he was i thought because
when i read the headline i was like
there's no way he's serious like i think
he was serious how does the doctor check
he just gets in there i guess the web is
still there
let me see what's going on in here
yeah it's like a stud finder they have a
spiderman left his mark and we're good
to go and he just walks out and fighting
that's [ __ ] weird i thought it was i
thought he was exaggerating no he had
this whole drama thing because he was
openly about
these weird standards that he has for
his daughter or whatever whatnot from a
guy who was a rapper that just talks
about [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time yeah
that's the weird thing the weird moral
thing it's like your
whole career was basically about you
know quote unquote whatever what's the
word misogyny or whatever yeah and then
yeah then you have like high standards
for your daughters like how does that
work out
yeah that's weird as [ __ ] dude that and
i see ti as a rule like [ __ ] slayer bro
i think that dude crushed it for sure
expeditiously he did and you know and
it's back then in the time where he was
famous bro any rapper
why is it why is it so wrong for other
people just to say that hispanic comedy
sucks and everybody immediately goes oh
you're just being a hater no he's saying
that ti fans no just people like in the
comments they're saying like well he's
trying nobody's saying he's not but when
you're doing stand-ups either we laugh
or we [ __ ] don't yeah it's very
objective as far as like yeah are you
funny or not yeah like we're just going
to laugh or we're not it doesn't mean
that you're being a hater you don't have
to like you stand up like we don't have
to like his music yeah right that's why
i'm saying like that's why stand-up is
so disrespected
it's just it's obnoxious yeah it's like
he's just trying do you say that about
everything like he's he's on a stage
yeah you know what i mean we're going to
judge what the [ __ ] he's doing like if i
go up but i do stand up and i do a tour
nobody shows up i'm gonna kill myself
right and then if you go david sucks
it's true at this point because the
facts are there sure
when people online have this really odd
thing of wanting to be able to say
whatever they want but they don't want
anybody to say anything about them
it's stupid
it's asinine listen if you go out there
and you type your little stupid comment
somebody has the right to go and write
something stupid right back to you
that's the give and take of things you
can't just create content and choose who
gets to see it and who gets to judge you
then it's not art it's not [ __ ] art
at all don't disrespect this space you
guys
you got a good point though cause i
remember you were on instagram talking
about that with uh guys who make recipes
yeah and then you were like if it looks
like [ __ ] i do get to
comment on it you could say it looks
like [ __ ] yeah you could say i think
everyone should be allowed to say
whatever the [ __ ] they want
my lovely genius farce this podcast is
brought to you by babble my friends if
you are trying to learn a language you
have to do it with babel i freaking love
babble you guys know prior to pandemic i
was traveling everywhere and learning a
few words or phrases in the correct way
is super important to me and babble has
been there for me not only is learning a
new language a fun and engaging new
hobby you can use it while you check off
traveling more from your list the whole
babel process is addictively fun fast
and easy babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons for real world use i
know for a fact you guys have taken
language classes where they taught you a
bunch of [ __ ] that you never ever
got to use because people just don't
talk like that babble is so freaking
different with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german my friends
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcast games video stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee so don't
[ __ ] worry just get babble i love
them right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
gb that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code gb there are reddit threads of
people literally
building voodoo dolls to kill me they
want me dead and i'm on that threat
people hate me dude why send me 50 bucks
and i'll get some of his hair for you
guys
by the way your voodoo dolls aren't
working i'm still here idiot
go to new orleans [ __ ]
you went to new orleans i did yeah you
know what's the business you're a good
segue dude
we're talking about traveling
it was sick dude new orleans is awesome
there is voodoo [ __ ] down there too
hella voodoo
there's voodoo houses and shits i was
telling this that you should go on ghost
tours there there's a bunch of haunted
places yeah it's trying to go ghostwork
tour no for what the [ __ ] yeah you take
one home with you bro go to new orleans
it's the best i want to go i don't want
to go i don't want to take no ghosts
it's debauchery they have a lot of weird
uh ghost stories and murder stories over
there like serial killer stuff there's
one really famous one where there was a
person i heard it's not true because it
was exaggerated but it was about a crazy
person
who had a trade hotel in the middle of
uh in between like these trade routes
and they would let guests come in but
the guests would never leave so what
would happen is that they would set up
this this bedroom
which is like partially true where um
they would you know set them up with
some tea and it's like a bed and
breakfast so they would give them
breakfast tea or whatever but the tea
was spiked so they would get dizzy and
they would pass out and fall asleep in
their bed but the bed would have a latch
and it would drop them into a dungeon
and they would murder them and
disassemble them whoa and sell organs
and i don't know they would just kill
all these [ __ ] and they
eventually found out they grabbed this
person or the townspeople found them and
then they were gonna hang her and then
she said some really [ __ ] creepy line
of basically you know whatever i'll i'll
see you guys in like in your nightmares
or your dreams or some [ __ ] and then she
gets hung up to death whoa
[ __ ] creepiest [ __ ] that's 100
percent true you're always freaky dude i
love you back then dude and everything
every everything is still old too like
it's like all original buildings like
it's everything's old as [ __ ] the bricks
in the buildings you could see the
fingerprints of the slaves who made the
bricks they still have slave quarters
too yeah like there's houses where
you'll see like the slave quarters where
they were
that's pretty crazy that sounds like a
nuts [ __ ] uh like a a wild and then
down that's a good time mardi gras
you're getting your dick sucked yeah
people just showing titties and just
disrespecting this whole history of this
whole place how many titties
are getting [ __ ] up hammered uh the
food is amazing that's something that's
your favorite willie mace willie mays
and then i had uh these acme oysters
fellow oysters acne oysters acme oysters
yeah dude
they're like baked or charbroiled i
don't know what they were but they're
grilled they're grilled they they had
dude it was one of the best things i've
ever had in my life butter billy mays
willie mays
the chicken
it's so good dude the the peas the green
beans i had these yams they were like
these these candy
every bite i was like this is the
[ __ ] best thing i've ever tasted in
my mind you have the beignets did you
get gumbo etouffee yes gumbo i got the
beignets at the cafe dumont po boys for
sure
new orleans po boys hella good dude
everything is good everything is good we
went to this other place seafood spot
they had this catfish like in this soup
like breaded catfish one of the best
things i've ever i was like i was like i
don't get it i was like getting mad i
was like this is too good the drinks
every everyone's cool as [ __ ] everyone's
talking [ __ ] we went to a breakfast spot
they're playing forget about dre like
it's like a [ __ ] breakfast spot like
a normal like family joint forget about
dre's eminem talking about [ __ ]
people in the ass that while we're
eating it's cool [ __ ] people are the
waiters are dancing
the guy the guy leaves wondering his
coffee is old ladies
yeah this old couple this old couple's
leaving the restaurant and the waiter's
like don't you forget about dre now
like that's just like
don't you dare forget about drake dude
that's the whole vibe i love that place
if you've never been to narlins new
orleans if
that's the only place you can get a
legit pull boy because po boys have a
very specific type of french bread it's
not the typical french beer that you get
anywhere else it's not a baguette it's a
po boy specific made french bread that
they have it's like their version of it
it's crusty and it's really chewy
that's the reason why you don't get to
have like authentic po-boys here because
you don't have that bread it's so it's
so good fried oysters in that [ __ ] i get
the fried oysters and fried shrimp is my
sh yeah i like the shrimp their portions
ridiculous dude i got a seafood platter
and a po boy i didn't know the seafood
platter killed all the [ __ ] living
creatures yeah yeah yeah and it was like
25 bucks and it could feed seven people
yeah dude
i'm telling you incredible also music
everywhere sickest bug also if you go do
the swamp tour you're getting a fanbot
like the [ __ ] the csi remember the
intro
so it was like a six uh cedar right
first of all
guide has no teeth cajun as [ __ ] barely
understand what was saying talking [ __ ]
about his wife the whole time he's
giving you the tour amazing so we're you
you you're on a fan boat and this
[ __ ] kicks it like you're going
fast dude in the winds you're like
it's louder [ __ ] fast wind you can't
even see and then he's driving towards
this mud like it's like a like the
hurricane created these little mud
mounds in the middle of the water he's
going towards an island like fast like
and i'm like all right this guy's going
to turn this guy's going to turn we're
getting closer i'm like this
[ __ ] better turn we're about to
crash
doesn't turn [ __ ] yeah
hits the mud thing we
in the air dude like this like i'm out
of my chair like this
drifts he's just going off islands dude
like 20 times it was sick as [ __ ] dude
i'm talking about like real hank like my
back hurt afterwards because we were
hitting the water so fast i don't give a
[ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ] he's like
high as hell he's like if anybody asked
back in the office we didn't do no no
jump sorry yeah
i was like i'm [ __ ] looking forward
to
turning around half the
don't ask me you know me that was a hell
of a ride you get crawfish craw i got
crawfish i got all that stuff you like
crawfish i like everything there
all right so you want to move there bro
i honestly would i wouldn't mind it's
kind of a little a little i don't know
if i would live there but it the vibe is
so cool it's like it's such a good
thought because you know at a hurricane
katrina the place still hasn't recovered
from them so when when you're in new
orleans specifically like the heart of
the city that's like their tourist
attraction area it's nice everywhere
else i wouldn't say everywhere else but
i talked to a couple people who were
there they're like honestly we're still
[ __ ] up from hurricane katrina isn't
that [ __ ] that they had like no help
yeah that's crazy and it's like to this
day
hey bush hates black
people and then michael myers was there
like she's like
cut well that's why when everybody's so
you know my free they freak out about
kanye west like what happened to him i
was like dude
he's been like this for quite a while
yeah he's always been like that he's
always been kind of a wild boy have you
watched the documentary yes i have yeah
and it's pretty good we were only on the
first episode but like when you see him
back then too you see like oh this is
the same kanye it's he's literally the
same person he's the same dude wait did
you sorry to cut did you see kim
kardashian selling [ __ ] to just
get up and work hard oh yeah
yeah tip was explained to me though
that's the last person you ever want to
hear that from ever get up and start
sucking dick and then put out a video
yeah boom boom
rich losers yeah
get [ __ ] up
so many women were pissed of course
everyone should be pissed i saw a video
of her
uh she was doing like tiff was showing
this to me and she was like this is so
stupid
and it was her like a black like
jumpsuit thing
and then she had um like yellow caution
tape but it was the name of a brand it
was uh
like a versace or something versace
ferragama whatever yeah balenciaga or
whatever yeah and she wrapped herself
all the way around in this yellow
caution tape with the brand name on it
and then she starts walking
down the aisle like a like a fashion
show with this tape on she couldn't
[ __ ] walk because she's covered in
yellow caution tape but like i watch
that and i think
who
wants to see this like who's asking
idiot for this type of and i guess
that's like i'm sure it's high fashion
it's like a whole [ __ ] industry
whatever but the whole time i'm watching
this i just can't help but to feel like
this is a waste of everybody's time oh
this is what i'm talking about we were
just talking about people's perception
of themselves it's just not there she
doesn't understand that she doesn't get
to have that position and talk to people
about hard work when you grew up rich on
a reality tv show making millions of
millions of dollars you did no work at
that even her own body it's like all
surgery
you didn't even work out at the gym to
get what you have that's true zero
percent zero percent what have you done
that has actually had any effort listen
and you know i get it too like just
because you have money doesn't mean that
you get to build an empire that she has
i understand but like people don't
understand like how you come off the
people who don't have your resources and
your means it does you don't get to say
that especially too like the generic of
advice of get up and work that doesn't
apply to just women it applies to people
in general what the [ __ ] are you getting
to [ __ ] work like dude that's some
hunger game [ __ ]
like that remember the hunger games and
the the elite that like they said wild
[ __ ] like these people work harder yeah
that's like that that's why you guys are
hungry all the time
you guys don't work hard enough it's
like i don't have any food well did you
eat yeah
did you do you have time today to sit
down and meditate about how you don't
have food right now yeah did you do your
did you hear meditation today people are
wild you know yoga helps a lot did she
also also trust two thousand dollars a
[ __ ] month honestly yeah yoga is so
expensive that god knows damn yeah you
know shout out to everybody that are
like looking for yoga like studios just
go on youtube they have all these
[ __ ] grapes there you go youtube uh
yogurt if you want to get touched up
just go to bikram and you're pretty much
good yeah you get molested but i
remember kim kardashian she got in
trouble too for
they had a birthday party i think it was
during the middle of the pandemic and
they rented out an island
didn't they and everybody was just like
yo like i just gonna rent out a whole
which is hey if you could rent that
island yeah more power to you but the
whole time we're all sitting here that's
what i'm saying like people who are like
the most least socially aware were the
people with money during pandemic when
people didn't have jobs they didn't have
money we're gonna be okay and they were
like uses time to focus on you yeah yeah
i don't have food yeah yeah right like
the audacity you think the single parent
got time to think about you know all the
stuff yeah they're just like oh you know
what use this time to focus on yourself
this was some of the best times for
reflection i got to stay in my house
like dude look at your home of course
it's nice your [ __ ] four bajillion
square foot home of course you're having
the time of your life not everybody
lives like that it's just nonsense
that's so funny damn
stupid
and that's what yeah that's why yeah you
beat me to it because like that's why
all those [ __ ] people started making
the songs about you know amazing it's
like please as i'm suffering
yeah what is that yeah and then the
apologize one remember the black and
white video you have to think like i'm
sorry yeah yeah that was all i apologize
to think you singing a song or a verse
of a song in collection of all these
other people that no one really gives a
[ __ ] about and the grand scheme of
things to make everyone feel better that
is craz that's mental illness like
that's gonna make me forget about my
grandmother dying i was watching that
video you know imagine all the people
doesn't matter i saw that video i'm good
i don't care how fine you are dude she's
pretty fine she's she's i mean look hey
she's [ __ ] fine john my wonder woman
what did she do wrong again i forgot
already yeah
who gives a [ __ ] she's all good
guys are sweet
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast gal gadot you
could catch patrick.riley on his
instagram's doing stand up check out his
shows and you could check nte strong
whoa whoa to get your fitness um
let's get into this
nick the ear let's not be pretentious
about fitness you know what i mean [ __ ]
how about that speak on it yeah yeah
somebody wrote the comments that nick
doesn't know anything about fitness and
that should make me laugh
i'm all right i'm gonna put a post it's
true i don't i'm gonna put a post on
next door about you being a piece of
[ __ ] that you're trying to touch me look
out for the band-aid boy see what he
says you try to [ __ ] me when we're doing
personal training you just praying every
sundays at 12 pm see y'all next time
peace